analysis of the most recent cdc data
available shows that firearms are the
leading cause of death among children in
this country surpassing car accidents
for the first time in 2020. state of
arkansas is fifth overall for firearm
deaths among kids under 17 and eighth
overall in total firearm fatalities per
capita the governor of that state asa
hutchinson served on an nra school
safety task force in the wake of the
sandy hook school shooting all things i
mentioned because asa hutchinson is here
with us governor good morning thank you
for being here
uh look we got a lot of problems in this
country there's a lot of things we could
talk about but uh school shootings and
shootings in churches and in
supermarkets they loom really large over
our culture and people are wondering is
there nothing that we can do to stop
them you said sunday there might be a
bipartisan group of governors who can
look at solutions what might those
solutions be
well first of all it's good to be with
you and there's probably not a more
important topic than the safety of our
children at schools we've done a lot in
arkansas
back in 2018 we had a school safety
commission that made recommendations on
enhancing the security of our schools
we've made a lot of progress in that
area
but we're a great nation
and we have to protect our children at
school
we send billions of dollars that i
support to ukraine uh we can also put in
the money that's necessary to protect
our schools and to protect our children
there that to me is the focal point of
the conversation i know that there is
another side of that which is mental
health uh and how we're dealing with
that in our schools and increasing
direct counseling uh but there's also uh
the aspect of what do we do about uh an
18 year old being able to go out and buy
uh an ar-15 that does that kind of
damage at the school and i've simply
said that that's a fair conversation to
have
uh and uh that's uh you know in arkansas
and in in
my
my thought in life is that i fully
support the second amendment
but we also
can legitimately look at what the
senator's considering and i applaud them
to have in a bipartisan group that looks
at
what can we agree upon and i think we
can have a conversation about whether
there ought to be a
age 21
requirement to acquire one of these
ar-15 military-style weapons it says a
lot about the state of our politics it
it's a big move to have a conversation
right i know you feel the same way again
i do and i keep thinking when we talk
about the second amendment
i still say they were talking about
muskets governor they were not talking
about the fire power that we have today
and don't we have to make uh adjustments
for that it seems that we all love
children we all agree that this is
terrible we wring our hands and say how
horrible it is until the next one
happens and it will happen again why is
it so difficult to get this right why is
it so hard to have the uncomfortable
conversation
that nobody should have a an assault
rifle unless you were a trained
professional and you're on a battlefield
why can't we just at least come to terms
with that i don't understand it well i i
think that we should not restrict uh the
type of weapon for those that are over
21
uh i mean we do i was a former united
states attorney i've prosecuted people
for firearms violation they improperly
acquire them we don't allow citizens to
have grenades also exactly and so there
are limits on the weaponry that
civilians can have
but we really do not want to take away
the right of our citizens to protect
themselves to enjoy it whether it is
a
type of gun that is a semi-automatic uh
you know we have those and it's just the
age limit between 18 and 21 that i think
is a fair part of the debate i think we
need to look at that more deeply and and
i don't and you know the senators are
looking at you know background
checks and how we can expand those
perhaps
but i think this is one the conversation
about whether you ought to be 21 to
acquire one of these well nobody wants
to take
weapons from responsible gun owners
that's right that's never the debate
i'm still hung up about these assault
rifles that cause tremendous damage as
you well know i'm not telling you
something you don't know and that we
just continue to allow this to happen
while we profess our love for children i
had one mother that says to me you know
we are sleeping with our our guns and
crying over our guns and letting our
children down it's a high cost for this
absolutely
talking about it yeah it is it is uh and
is it worth that it's it's the uh
america is not going to be europe we're
not going to have the uh gun
restrictions that even canada is looking
at and you know in arkansas we're the
only country where this happens though
right and listen
we understand that this is a great
country yeah we can all agree with you
yes but i feel like we are failing we're
failing our people we're failing our
kids um and you mentioned mental health
we're not being dismissed as dismissive
of that um we're talking about these
assault rifles but why is it that it
happens so much more often here in the
united states versus other places
there's mental health issues in other
countries so
doesn't it boil down to taking these
types of weapons off the streets and out
of the hands of individuals that want to
do damage well the criminals are going
to get those i think what you've got to
look at are those with
mental health issues and that's a focal
point we want to keep them out of the
hands of those that
can do this kind of of harm uh and then
secondly again i think you have to look
at the level of maturity whenever you
have
uh you know a semi-automatic that can do
the damage that we see with the ar-15
style weapon and so we have to be
careful about this conversation one
constancy though is
we can
protect our children with better
security in the schools it did not work
in uvalde we can improve that
we can invest in that and that's an
important part of it as well so i
applaud the senators that have all of
this on the table and we have to
get away from being so divided and say
is there something we can agree upon
it's going to be narrow it's going to be
focused but the question is will it make
a difference a governor it's not just
schools it's concerts churches festivals
there was a shooting at a car show in
arkansas this isn't just about shootings
in schools mass shootings happen
everywhere in the united states sure and
the private sector is taking steps you
go into uh you know a shopping center
they have security guards there we're
protecting uh our private sector venues
well let's protect uh in an equal way
and even a more important way our
schools yeah and to me
while that might not solve what some
want to do with more gun control it does
protect our citizens and that's
something that is absolutely essential
it is a high cost to get into freedom
though you go to the mall you see armed
guards you go to school you see armed
guards right that's a different kind of
society we thank you for having me
thank you we do really appreciate it we
can talk to you all day long yeah we
could thank you